[Music]
this is mount pilatus in lucerne
switzerland
more than 100 years ago a group of
entrepreneurs developed revolutionary
technology and built a railway to get to
the top of the mountain faster
it is still the steepest of its kind in
the world
[Music]
the trip to the summit used to take a
day on foot and on mule back now it was
possible in under 40 minutes
this innovation put pilatus on the map
a similar revolution is going on in
switzerland today
fintech entrepreneurs are reinventing
the financial sector making it simpler
cheaper and more convenient together
with banks they hope to bring swiss
banking into the digital age
i am swiss and an entrepreneur i
launched my first startup in switzerland
in 1996. founded additional companies in
america and japan and wrote books on
finance and entrepreneurship
it seems to me switzerland as a
financial center and fintech are a
natural match but we also face
circumstances quite different from other
countries
to get a better idea of the state of
fintech in switzerland i visited
founders of swiss fintech startups
investors bankers and politicians
they told me about their experiences
challenges and dreams for fintech made
in switzerland
[Music]
i think the first wave was largely
euphoria it was unclear how we could use
technology profitably and disruptively
in financial services
there was a lot of trial and error
we had to wait and see which technology
existed and how we could use it
what technology means in general not
just to finance is that
costs of doing things get reduced and
things becomes more effective
and whenever this happens labor gets
freed up which can be used on other
things and you will see wealth creation
there are two ways to look at it one is
the general perception of fintech this
is largely from the viewpoint of
self-service b2c and attackers of the
existing financial sector
this is one way to look at it but there
is much more in fact this is about
digitization less of things you see on
the front end but how we will create
value in the future in the financial
sector
if you look at uber it's still about
driving a taxi but it's so much easier
you press the button the taxi arrives
you get in and that was it i think it
will be similar with many financial
services
they will get much easier for
customers we can offer services directly
to customers this is the main difference
these aren't necessarily new business
models we couldn't imagine a decade ago
we certainly knew it was possible back
then but customers weren't ready because
they didn't have the technology to take
advantage
convenience is certainly what customers
will enjoy on a broad spectrum that's
where we're heading
perhaps less spectacular but i think if
somebody described five years ago how to
optimize the taxi business with uber the
description alone probably wasn't that
spectacular but if you can use the
service today it is very spectacular
if you have a field of business and you
are subject to what is called disruption
and disruption is if you
are heavily into the taxi business and
along comes uber
or you are
running a wholesale chain and along
comes airbnb
or you're running a bank and along comes
bitcoin those that will do well is those
that
that adapt to the new technology and
those that will
not or maybe even turn hostile will
become a casualty of history
it is much easier to digitize a media
company than a bank but technology is
capable of doing that now so it
certainly will
everything that can become more
efficient will as always in economic
history
this also applies to the highly
regulated financial sector
the financial crisis certainly harmed
the industry's reputation but we can
also repair a lot of things
we have to put people back at the center
and think how we can use technology to
make finance work to the benefit of
people again
if we can do this then we have achieved
something and will also make a lot of
money and it will be a lot of fun
because we managed to build something
great
if you have this repertoire at your
fingertips you can play wrong notes or
you can play bach
taking advantage of the opportunity to
play bach and the pleasure to be
creative is still missing
people see the danger but not the
opportunity
we certainly see this as an opportunity
of course change can always go both ways
but in general we see this as a great
opportunity
if you look at the recent years it
worked really well we said we put people
at the center we use technology to offer
new services that were previously
unavailable and we bring these services
to market
this has worked really well
i don't see why this should change if we
continue on this path
i want to
work with something that matters
and where you can significantly improve
the lives of
maybe the whole world population i mean
that's ambitious but you know eighty
percent of the world's population do not
have access to banking
so they can't trade
with anybody that they can't see
and thus they are poor
this is something we can do much better
when finance
if finance can't improve the lives of
people we have no use for it
it cannot become an ancillary discipline
of economics
finance exists to reduce risks for
people to improve returns for people's
pensions
never since the end of the second world
war such great opportunities existed in
this industry as today
this is the best time for the financial
sector if they take advantage of this
opportunity
i have been an entrepreneur since
university for the last 10 years
this is my second company
the first couple of months was a bit
difficult to get the first client
clients on board which i find
well pretty natural i guess in the
financial industry because there's a lot
of trust going into
into
this industry
insurance brokering what we did at knip
neither dennis nor me had any idea of
the insurance business
we started by saying let's think from
the perspective of the customer
this was the secret of our success
because we didn't think like people in
the insurance industry who did things
the traditional way but we applied
digital know-how to the insurance
business
the step from a traditional bank like
ubs to a fintech company was not a big
step
finance is finance
the interesting thing was how we could
use technology to be different
is
so we knew that we could sell our
product
we decided to take on a little more risk
and founded a company exclusively for
this product
we also found investors who believed in
us
together we developed a business and in
the last two years our client base
increased by factor 10.
because we put a great emphasis on
flexibility we we often tried to come up
with a good solution for our clients and
then things started to take off more and
more clients joined the platform and uh
now all of a sudden we have uh
quite a great growth rate
i often went to the office with a big
smile on my face with a rush of
endorphins
on the other hand as a startup founder
you let all this get very close to you
being an entrepreneur not only means
taking risks but also having privileges
being creative creating something new
this has a lot of value
in switzerland we should present
entrepreneurship honestly like it really
is
the culture of a bank is certainly
different from a three-year-old tech
startup
some reasons i understand and others
less so
many companies in the in the fintech
square and that was also kind of how the
general public saw it was that okay now
these fintech companies are here and
they would like to kind of out compete
the banks over the next 10 years banking
is going to be dead in 10 years but i
don't think that is the way to go i
think banks have been around for way too
long for that to happen the
infrastructure is there the relationship
with their clients are there
so what you have to do in order to be
successful in the market both being a
bank or being a fintech company is to
see where can where can your interest
actually overlap and where can you find
collaboration opportunities and see how
you can kind of grow together
this process took about 10 months
probably quite fast for a bank but for
us it was sometimes a game of patience
but after about a year we released our
solution and that was really a milestone
for us and also for our customers
all big ideas started in a garage
apple didn't start in an incubator but
in a garage
i first have to prove my solution has
legs that it works in test markets and
from that big things emerge
when our big venture round came that was
an entirely new game
also when we expanded to germany with a
market 10 times as big as switzerland
and all this in a very short time
these were all huge milestones that we
and our team had to process
first we were two people then 10 then 30
50 70 120 that was a big challenge but
also a fantastic challenge
[Music]
we looked at the margins in our mortgage
lending business and quite frankly had a
shock
we needed to do something urgently
growing in mortgage lending with little
risk is tough so we had to think of
other options
digitization certainly lowers barriers
to entry
you can get to the market with a good
idea more easily
but the same thing is true for us banks
as well
our approach at credit suisse is
participating in the relevant topics and
seeing how we can integrate ideas coming
from startups in our digital offerings
what we did differently was that we
began a strong outreach
we approached startups vcs consultants
technology providers of all kinds also
regulators politicians or interested
clients our ecosystem is extremely broad
i am the only one in our team with a
banking background everybody else has a
totally different background media
professionals a physicist a lawyer an
artist somebody coming from an ngo
a broad selection so we can have a
varied approach
also people who had their own startups
who said i have an idea i start a
company
internet
are swiss customers internet savvy
enough to get a mortgage online without
stepping into a bank
we believed in this business case
and it was great to see it took off
shortly after launch
today it is the flagship of our online
offerings and it also gave us the
reputation as the most digital bank in
switzerland
the process is usually more complex than
it looks like from the outside
but we have cooperative and proactive
meetings and we're looking for solutions
startups want to work with us and we
also want to innovate in the end we find
a solution
we have to manage a world of two
velocities a relatively low velocity
within the organization to ensure
stability but outwardly we have to
become more efficient and faster
especially with fintech companies and
other tech companies
what are the mistakes of the media
industry what are the mistakes that
kodak made
we try to avoid the same mistakes we
have an advantage we're not the first
industry undergoing this paradigm shift
the agility and the mentality of fintech
startups experimenting being fast
learning also leaving the traditional
path
companies definitely need to do this as
well in the future
why should the customer not replace me
why am i better i can work with physical
elements that enhance the digital world
or i have to be half a step ahead of the
competition and anticipate what
customers want next
we shouldn't think customers are slow in
the digital world they can be very fast
if we made all these digital offerings
just for fun with nothing to show on our
balance sheet people would hardly call
us the most digital bank in switzerland
or invite us to conferences to present
our case
impressive thing is that we tried
something new and we are successful with
it
all banks are in motion now we see this
in the associations we are part of the
swiss bankers association has an expert
group for fintech economy swiss has an
expert group secco wants to form an
expert group
now we have a little too many expert
groups but the pitch has sunk in
this is here to stay and we have to deal
with it i would strongly advise against
using the term cannibalization
this is a complement to the existing
business model and those who won't
change will lose
clinging to traditional business models
for too long is dangerous
on the other hand it is also unnecessary
to let them go too early
with many things you first have to build
a foundation and the use cases will
follow
all in all there are a thousand little
steps that will develop into something
very robust in the end
[Music]
switzerland as one of the world's
fintech startup hubs we can be a world
leader especially in the insurance
industry but in banking we have to catch
up so switzerland as a financial center
can play a central role in the future
in recent years associations and
conferences have mushroomed to create
global awareness for fintech in
switzerland and also help pressure the
regulatory
the reason for this is the realization
that switzerland is a banker's nation
number one in wealth management but
we're not on the global fintech map
from an investor's perspective
switzerland is certainly no hub today
with an extreme draw for fintech
startups
many models originate in switzerland
like in other places as well
we have good framework conditions in
general because we have a strong
financial industry but we're nowhere
near berlin and london
startups with more than 100 staff after
a few years of operations are scarce in
switzerland if you look at the number of
such startups in berlin or london you
have a mild shock they hire more people
each month than the entire head count of
companies in switzerland after three or
four years
we are a small country we have a very
small market and digital business is
primarily a bulk business it scales with
market
what we are lacking in fintech are swiss
companies that succeed beyond the swiss
german or the french german market
those that want to become market leaders
in europe or in the world in some areas
the thing i'd like to see more of in
switzerland
is slightly more unreasonable
entrepreneurs because it's those that
have to figure out
how can i as a tiny company really
become a world leader in this new field
that takes an unreasonableness
and a turning back on everything that
if you like your education has told you
you should be
i understand that switzerland doesn't do
industrial policy
that's the fact that people tell me all
the time one has to accept that but the
world is moving on and other countries
do industrial policy for fintech
this new world is not about an ego
system revolving around one person alone
but an ecosystem where we all work
together at eye level that is still
missing and needs more work
this is completely different in other
countries where you have a much bigger
community aggressively working on new
ideas
we don't have that in switzerland
therefore the pressure to work together
is much lower
we have a bit of a feel-good society in
the financial sector in switzerland
still
switzerland as a financial center should
collectively make the decision to move
forward
instead there is a lack of coordination
and financial resources some people
think everything is okay this is just
not true
when i speak with politicians i find
most of them have no clue what fintech
is
i strongly believe a large startup fund
would be important for the swiss fintech
ecosystem
with large i mean 500 to 1 billion swiss
francs
this capital should be available for
series a and series b rounds for bigger
tickets for swiss startups
in my opinion we have the money for
instance from pension funds
the only thing missing is somebody
taking the lead and orchestrating it
silicon valley began like this it is so
successful because of the large amount
of venture capital that is available
there
it is a close-knit cluster with an
extreme dynamism
we have excellent conditions in
switzerland to build something similar
in fintech in the next five years
if you have all the talent available in
this factory why not simply do it
the most frustrating thing is that it
needs a relatively small amount of money
why not invest in young people young
entrepreneurs who give an arm and a leg
to create jobs
why not put only 0.1
such a tiny amount in some kind of
government fund for swiss entrepreneurs
i just don't understand
the train has not yet pulled away
completely
we absolutely have a chance to catch up
but we would have to go at it at full
speed
the times in my life when i've achieved
the most is when i put myself in danger
the most
and it is interesting because there's
something about the human condition and
performance
in that
i believe that we perform at our best
when we challenge ourselves a little bit
sure there are obstacles but i learned
to ignore them sometimes you have to say
just put an obstacle in my path i'll
walk around it
innovation in business is not coming
from inside companies there must be
exceptions but in general it does not
come from within
crowdfunding
topics like crowdfunding or blockchain
or sharing economy aren't obvious for a
bank
nevertheless we began to investigate
what we can do with the blockchain how
we can integrate it in our business or
how to interface with other companies
and if this all makes sense
blockchain is finance and technology so
it is fintech by definition
still it is somewhat separate from the
fintech scene and i often wondered why
one reason is that it is very
ideological
many people with a focus on bitcoin or
cryptocurrency don't want to launch a
startup simply to make money they want
to revolutionize the financial system
it is extremely important for a company
to open its doors to accept new ideas
and new business models into its own
culture
first we encouraged our employees to
submit new business ideas
at some point we realized that we
shouldn't restrict innovation to our own
staff
the world should be our playground so
why not invite everybody to participate
scouting is relatively straightforward
that's the case with us too we have a
lot of good ideas coming to us from the
outside
many startups contact us and want to
collaborate
the real challenge is to accept the
ideas into the company a healthy
business location is like a forest
if you're frantically trying to support
all the old trees that's unsustainable
the sustainable approach is to say okay
sometimes an old tree will fall down
because it has become rotten and brittle
but new trees have space to grow in its
place
the biggest danger lies in preventing
the growth of new trees
for instance if regulatory overhead is
so large that startups can't afford it
i think we were sometimes better off if
we took a little more risk
the way forward consists of many small
experiments
those that succeed will help you develop
you can reach a point that allows you to
create new revenue streams or a new
customer experience
but the one big leap directly into the
honey pot i don't think it exists
if a bank can adapt fast enough i don't
think its business model is in danger
difficult is deploying a new technology
innovation is not mastering a new
technology but deploying it in the
market
if we look back in 10 years in 2026
maybe we watch this video and what we
said back then
i think we will have to deal with things
that we currently don't have on our
radar
the management must learn to live with
this tension
evolve constantly and if you have enough
facts to make a decision make it boldly
and go down this path or another or also
abandon an idea once in a while
[Music]
in 10 years i imagine new technology and
blockchain in particular will bring
fundamental change that we can't fully
take into account today especially in
financial intermediation
with this i mean the functions of
intermediaries that technology could
fully replace
in the end digitization will concern us
all
i still wonder what exactly a digital
hairdresser will look like
i haven't quite found one yet but for
almost all other areas i have some idea
what digitization will look like
the changes will be fundamental
we better think about possible scenarios
and how we will live together in the
future
i also talk a lot about the possibility
of doing things but relatively few
people actually do it
for instance emit a swiss franc coin on
the blockchain or found a digital
autonomous organization that performs a
service
some tools are still missing for that
which all software developers depend on
but in general what's missing is the
spirit to just do it
excellent fintech companies exist in
switzerland
not that many but fantastic companies
that managed to team up with large banks
and create substantial value
it's a beautiful image the traditional
bank that has existed for 100 or 150
years
and a fintech entrepreneur who is
perhaps 30 years old who launched his
company just a few years ago
he managed to solve a problem in the
market together with a bank
i salute these entrepreneurs and we need
more of them
it's a fantastic opportunity for zurich
as a business location to take advantage
of technological innovations in finance
to think about new ideas and establish
them and strengthen the financial sector
in which zurich is already a leader
the swiss way to work together is very
special
our distances are short
somebody from geneva can come to burn
somebody from zurich can come to bern
and we all meet up in bern
that's different from flying to
singapore or new york
and using video chat is still not the
same as sitting face to face
we have a lot of know-how in this
country
banking is in our dna not just chocolate
and cheese with ubs we have the biggest
wealth manager in the world
blackrock said switzerland is important
strategically
we have a lot of good brands with a lot
of know-how
i came to switzerland three years ago i
co-founded knip and then the association
swiss finance startups
everybody gave me a heartfelt warm
welcome i don't take that for granted
and i give switzerland great credit for
it
if you invest a lot in the effort in
being an entrepreneur and i'm sure you
know that yourself
you might as well do it on as firm a
foundation as possible
because it would be very
sad to invest so many years and
sacrifices
only to found that you were in a
jurisdiction that will pull the carpet
away from under you switzerland has an
excellent jurisdiction not only for
fintech or blockchain technology but
in a very large number of areas deprive
privacy privacy security digital
identity we are the country of human
rights neutral and politically stable
perfect for a global solution
especially in switzerland the trust in
banks and insurance companies is still
massive
let me ask you a question if you could
have a financial service from google or
apple or from an established swiss bank
which will you choose
independent of age or class people have
rock solid trust in swiss banks and
insurance companies
if we managed to develop a disruptive
business model in switzerland perhaps
with know-how from a bank and swiss
universities
this would be an excellent success story
for switzerland
a country with eight million people
developed a fintech lighthouse project
that people in singapore enthuse about
people in london are watching it
starry-eyed wouldn't this be the best
marketing
we plan to establish a blockchain
research hub in zurich i hope we will
succeed
this concerns more than the financial
sector alone it equally applies to the
insurance industry there may be new
sectors we don't even imagine for which
we can become providers
i think switzerland has an excellent
talent pool
we have knowledge and the reputation
that we should put to good use the point
is to transform finance to fintech the
financial know-how is here still
how can we transform it into the future
into the digital world
it's a fact we don't have natural
resources like oil or gas
we mainly have our brain and our talent
for innovation
these are our strengths and we should
build on them we should cultivate them
and we have this opportunity
i think we can play a leading role in
this market in the world and also
strengthen the swiss financial center
she's
mean launch or treats very my advice for
the swiss people is the following
have courage and become entrepreneurs
take risks and don't feel discouraged in
case you fail
if we have more startup founders an
ecosystem will form
founders attract investors they again
attract innovation labs from large
corporations such as ubs with level 39
in london
this will create momentum that cannot be
stopped i think crypto will help
bring transparency to to finance but
certainly also democracize it the beauty
is we don't have to take on huge risks
just be a little less risk averse than
everybody else
and already we're the best business
location people will become more more
open-minded to actually financing maybe
the business that you have around the
block rather than just putting your
money on the stock market so when people
become more and more open around this i
think it creates different type of
community
[Music]
the opportunity to develop new ideas
with innovative clients it's great fun
an amazing time
that's my wish that we all work together
on the swiss fintech ecosystem
there's the ecosystem between banks and
startups many are doing this and it is
sexy but it's also about banks working
together among themselves
not against each other with each other
let's not put our own interests first
but think about what the swiss financial
sector needs to catch up
the way forward is taking the strengths
of startups and taking the strengths of
banks and seeing how they together can
create value for customers there's one
characteristic that i think is very
interesting here in switzerland that you
have some of the biggest traditional
rivals
collaborating
wow the unity switzerland is showing
here is unique and it differentiates
itself in the world
this is extremely positive
but the government should also be part
of this it needs to create the right
structure and regulatory environment
banks fintech companies the government
politicians we should all together push
this forward
we have to explain what's happening in
switzerland and why startups should come
here
and we should learn from the americans
and the british to make a little more
noise and do marketing
be convinced that we want to be the
global hub for fintech in three or four
topics
this is what i wish for
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you